wherever king charles iii and the queen
consort camilla travel the walkabouts go
well the cheers are much the same but
this is northern ireland it's unlike
anywhere else in the uk there's division
here protestant unionists and loyalists
are passionate about the monarchy she
was our queen but he is not our king and
god save the king
i think he's uh
good for the job yeah be as good as the
queen was
but these areas in west belfast are
quiet catholic republicans and
nationalists are dismissive
and i think in the middle of a cost 11
crisis where many many people in my
consistency here and right across
belfast in the north where people can't
afford to hit their homes i think it's
obscene that you have a monarch and a
king who will be hitting his palaces at
the expense of the public purse
first stop for the royal visit is
hillsborough castle the royal residence
political leaders gather and there's a
message of condolence
alex maskey was a firebrand republican
in the 80s and 90s now in government as
speaker of the northern ireland assembly
she personally demonstrated how
individual acts of positive leadership
can help break down barriers and
encourage reconciliation
queen elizabeth showed that a small but
significant gesture
a visit a handshake crossing the street
or speaking a few words of irish can
make a huge difference in changing
attitudes and building relationships
politics have changed dramatically here
and king charles believes his mother was
able to use a combination of skills to
bring the two sides closer
at the very beginning
of her life
of service
the queen made a pledge
to dedicate herself
to her country and her people
and to maintain the principles of
constitutional government
this promise she kept
with steadfast faith
now with that shining example before me
and with god's help
i take up my new duties resolved to seek
the welfare
of all the inhabitants of northern
ireland
from a castle to the church saint anne's
cathedral and a service of reflection on
the queen's life all 96 years of it the
theme here once again
reconciliation
a congregation of nearly 800 packed the
cathedral to hear praise of the queen
for her work in bringing northern
ireland's republican unionist
communities closer together
in 2011 she had visited the irish
republic making major gestures of
reconciliation
a year later in belfast she shook hands
with the late martin mcguinness a former
ira commander
shin fein is now the biggest party in
northern ireland what they've been
careful to do however is to separate the
person of the queen from the symbolism
of the monarchy which as far as
republicans are concerned is associated
with
imperialism and colonialism
and rule in ireland for centuries um
however they are able to develop a
relationship
with the queen now whether
that will continue with the new king is
another matter
king charles may have popularity this is
his 40th visit here the first as monarch
he's pledged to follow in his mother's
footsteps and seek the welfare of all
the people in northern ireland his
relations with both sides of the divide
here is one of the first big tests of
his reign
andrew simmons al jazeera belfast